It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会过期的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Have you ever been sitting in a quiet room when someone starts chewing gum, and suddenly that sound is all you can hear? For most of us, it's mildly annoying. But for people with misophonia, certain sounds like chewing, coughing, or pen-clicking can trigger an intense emotional response that feels completely out of proportion to the stimulus. We're talking anxiety, disgust, rage, even panic. For a long time, misophonia was a lot of time. dismissed as just being overly sensitive or irritable. But researchers are now recognizing it as a genuine condition with neurological underpinnings. They're using brain imaging and other methods
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会对数据流量进行降速处理。你有没有过这样的经历：坐在安静的房间里，突然有人开始嚼口香糖，那一刻，你耳中仿佛只能听到那个声音？对我们大多数人来说，这只是轻微的烦恼。但对于患有恐音症（misophonia）的人来说，咀嚼、咳嗽或按动圆珠笔等特定声音可能会引发强烈的情绪反应，这种反应与刺激源完全不成比例。我们指的是焦虑、厌恶、愤怒，甚至是恐慌。长期以来，恐音症往往被简单地斥为过度敏感或易怒。但研究人员现在正将其视为一种具有神经学基础的真实病症。他们正在利用脑成像和其他方法
to understand why certain sounds provoke such extreme reactions in some people and are working to educate the public and develop tools to help people cope. So how common is misophonia? What exactly is happening in the brain when someone hears a triggering sound? Why do some say, sounds bother people with misophonia while other sounds don't. Is misophonia related to such conditions as anxiety or obsessive compulsive disorder? And what can people do if they're living with misophonia or living with someone who has it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Heather Hansen, an assistant
来了解为什么某些声音会在一些人身上引发如此极端的反应，并致力于教育公众，开发帮助人们应对的工具。那么，恐音症有多普遍？当一个人听到触发声音时，大脑中到底发生了什么？为什么有些人说，恐音症患者会被某些声音困扰，而其他声音却不会。恐音症是否与焦虑症或强迫症等疾病有关？如果患有恐音症，或者与患有此症的人共同生活，人们该怎么办？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是希瑟·汉森（Heather Hansen）博士，她是威廉与玛丽学院的心理学助理
Professor of Psychology at the College of William and Mary. Dr. Hansen uses behavioral, physiological, and neuroimaging methods to study misophonia. She's explored the types of sounds that can act as triggers, what's happening in the brains of people who are triggered, and how misophonia affects people's cognitive and social judgments. Dr. Hanson is also the director of the Misophonia Research Network, an interdisciplinary international network of scientists and clinicians that aims to a advance misophonia research. Dr. Hanson, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with the basics. How is misophonia different from merely finding certain sounds annoying?
教授。汉森博士利用行为、生理和神经影像学方法研究恐音症。她探索了哪些类型的声音可以作为触发因素，被触发者的大脑中发生了什么，以及恐音症如何影响人们的认知和社会判断。汉森博士还是恐音症研究网络（Misophonia Research Network）的主任，这是一个由科学家和临床医生组成的跨学科国际网络，旨在推动恐音症的研究。汉森博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从基础开始。恐音症与仅仅觉得某些声音烦人有什么不同？
Yeah, great question. We all find certain sounds annoying, right? I think the key difference to me is that with misophonia, it is causing significant impairment to your daily life. So it's doing something different that makes you change your behavior. It's making you need to leave the room. It's making you reduce or or making your social interactions worse. It's impairing your ability to hold down a job, for instance. It's doing a lot more than just, man, that's annoying. That person's rude. It's like, oh, no, I've got to change what I am doing because of it.
嗯，这是一个很好的问题。我们都会觉得某些声音很烦人，对吧？我认为对我来说，关键的区别在于，恐音症会对你的日常生活造成严重的损害。它产生的影响让你不得不改变自己的行为。它让你需要离开房间。它让你减少社交互动，或者让你的社交互动变得更糟。例如，它损害了你保住工作的能力。它所做的不仅仅是“天哪，真烦人，那个人真没礼貌”。它更像是“哦，不，我必须因为这个声音而改变我正在做的事情”。
When did researchers start recognizing misophonia as a distinct condition? I think the earliest research has come from around 2001. So this is still relatively new compared to a lot of other disorders. And it came from different patients presenting to folks with audiology. So an audiologist who studies sound and hearing, I think the original was from the gesture of off back of 2001 where a participant was like, hey, I've got this weird thing where I'm having trouble. Like I have a reduced tolerance for certain sounds, but not all sounds, like help me out.
研究人员是什么时候开始将恐音症识别为一种独立病症的？我认为最早的研究大约始于 2001 年。所以与许多其他疾病相比，这仍然相对较新。它源于不同的患者向听力学专家咨询。听力学家研究声音和听力，我认为最初的案例来自 2001 年的贾斯特罗夫（Jastreboff）等人，当时一位参与者说：“嘿，我有一种奇怪的情况，我遇到了麻烦。我对某些声音的耐受力降低了，但不是所有声音，请帮帮我。”
And that's when people were like, hey, this is a little bit different than other sound disorders I've heard. It's a little bit different than like tinnitus or hyperacusis or some of the other audiological kind of conditions. There seems to be something different going on here. And so kind of in conjunction throughout the early 2010s, similar things were happening. So similar patients with misophonia were presenting to UCC and Diego, a group who studies synesthesia, which is when you kind of link two different sensory systems together. And they were like, hey, I'm, I am having this really averse negative reaction to certain sounds. Is that a normal sensory connection? Like, what is this? And so those researchers also put together, hey, this is a little bit different
那时人们意识到，嘿，这和我听说过的其他声音障碍有点不同。它与耳鸣、听觉过敏或其他一些听力学方面的疾病有点不同。这里似乎发生了些不一样的事情。因此，在 2010 年代初，类似的情况也在发生。患有恐音症的类似患者向加州大学圣地亚哥分校的一个研究联觉（synesthesia）的团队求助，联觉是指将两种不同的感官系统联系在一起。他们说：“嘿，我对某些声音有这种非常强烈的负面反应。这是一种正常的感官连接吗？这是什么？”因此，那些研究人员也意识到，嘿，这有点不同
than what we study. What is this condition? And so it originally got the name misophonia back in 2001. And since then, we have better understood it. We have more of a consensus definition now. We have acknowledged that it's a different thing than other conditions. And it is getting a lot more attention now than it was 20 years ago, which is nice. We did an episode on synesthesia a couple of years ago. So is there a A link between the two is like misophonia, the ugly side of synesthesia? I think the research is still out there. Personally, I would say they're a little bit different because I think I typically think
于我们所研究的内容。这到底是什么病症？所以它在 2001 年最初被命名为“恐音症”。从那时起，我们对它有了更好的了解。我们现在有了更一致的定义。我们承认它与其他疾病不同。而且它现在比 20 年前受到了更多的关注，这很好。我们几年前做过一期关于联觉的节目。那么两者之间有联系吗？恐音症是联觉的“丑陋面”吗？我认为研究尚无定论。就我个人而言，我会说它们有点不同，因为我认为我通常认为
of synesthesia as involving multiple senses per se. So like your vision and audition or color and music or whatever that looks like. To me, I think misophonia is a little bit more of a social context kind of thing than it is pure sensory intake. And so I think it's maybe there's some commonalities, but I think it's a little different to me. How common is misophonia and is it really rare or does it affect a significant portion of the population? More than you think. So early research landed on about like 20% of the population.
联觉涉及多种感官本身。比如你的视觉和听觉，或者颜色和音乐，无论它看起来是什么样。对我来说，我认为恐音症更多是一种社会背景下的产物，而不是纯粹的感官摄入。所以我认为也许有一些共同点，但我认为它对我来说有点不同。恐音症有多普遍？它真的很罕见吗，还是影响了很大一部分人口？比你想象的要多。所以早期的研究认为大约占人口的 20%。
Some more recent research, though, that does a little bit more like random sampling from the population, has landed closer to about 5%. So there was a study recently that came out in the U.S. that about 5% of adults from a representative sample have clinical or really impairing misophonia symptoms. And similar groups, I think a matching study in Germany and there was a couple in Turkey that found really similar numbers. So it seems to be something pretty consistent across the world, which is cool. The short answer is it is more common than you think in the 5% range. But I will caveat a little bit. And that is that we still don't have a great way of diagnosing it yet.
不过，一些更近期的研究对人口进行了更随机的抽样，得出的比例接近 5%。美国最近的一项研究表明，在具有代表性的样本中，约有 5% 的成年人患有临床上或严重损害功能的恐音症症状。我认为在德国和土耳其也有类似的匹配研究，发现了非常相似的数字。所以这似乎在世界各地都相当一致，这很有趣。简短的回答是，它比你想象的要普遍，在 5% 的范围内。但我会稍微提醒一下。那就是我们目前还没有很好的诊断方法。
So a lot of groups have created their own scales to try to figure out this issue. They've created their own assessments to be like, here's how I am going to assess. misophony in my participants. But the downside of that is that we're all kind of leading to slightly different numbers in our own research. So until we have like a universal accepted way of assessing misophonia, we're going to get slightly different numbers throughout our research. So if somebody came to you and said, I think I have it, what would you do? How would you test them? What would be the things that they would have to go through to determine whether, you know, I'm just a little bit irritable or I really have this disorder? Yeah. So I,
所以很多团队创建了自己的量表来试图弄清楚这个问题。他们创建了自己的评估方法，比如：“这就是我评估参与者恐音症的方法。”但缺点是，我们在各自的研究中得出的数字略有不同。因此，在我们拥有普遍认可的恐音症评估方法之前，我们的研究得出的数字会略有差异。如果有人来找你说：“我觉得我有这个病”，你会怎么做？你会如何测试他们？他们需要经历什么才能确定，你知道，我只是有点易怒，还是真的患有这种疾病？是的。所以，
because there's not like a diagnostic tool per se, and also disclaimer, I'm not a clinical psychologist, so I don't have the training to diagnose myself. But what I'd be interested in is to know exactly what happens to your physiological reaction, to your behavior. When you're hearing a sound, you claim you don't like. So some people are like, man, I hate chewing. That person's super annoying. But then maybe if you measure their skin conductance, how much they're sweating when they hear chewing, it's just like a normal amount compared to other people. So I would like to know if you're hearing a sound that you claim you do not like or a sound that triggers you, I would like to know whether that actually gives you a body reaction, if that actually makes you need to leave the room, if that impairs things about your ability to pay attention or to study a paragraph and be able to, you know,
因为没有所谓的诊断工具，而且免责声明一下，我不是临床心理学家，所以我没有受过诊断的培训。但我感兴趣的是确切了解当你听到你声称不喜欢的某种声音时，你的生理反应和行为会发生什么。有些人会说：“天哪，我讨厌咀嚼声。那个人太烦人了。”但如果你测量他们的皮肤电导，即他们听到咀嚼声时出汗的程度，这与其他人相比只是正常水平。所以我想知道，如果你听到一个你声称不喜欢的声音或一个触发你的声音，我想知道这是否真的会引起你的身体反应，是否真的让你需要离开房间，是否会损害你集中注意力或学习一段文字并能够（你知道）
recall information from it, things like that. So I test more of the cognitive effects of misophonia to figure out if it's actually causing you impairment instead of just like, yeah, I think I have it kind of situation. situation. What kinds of sounds typically trigger misophonic responses? And is there something that these sounds have in common or do they vary from person to person? This is the million dollar question. This is what started my research program. So commonly, if you, you know, Google misophonia, you'll see that misophonia is an aversion to chewing, to breathing, to sniffling, to sounds that are typically from the mouth of the nose. So some researchers really early on were like, maybe this is like a health-discussed kind of reaction. Maybe people with misophonia have that normal aversion to who, sniffling means, you know, sickness. I don't want to get sick. I don't want to be near someone
回忆信息的能力，等等。所以我更多地测试恐音症的认知影响，以确定它是否真的对你造成了损害，而不是仅仅处于“是的，我觉得我有这种情况”的阶段。什么类型的声音通常会触发恐音症反应？这些声音有什么共同点吗，还是因人而异？这是价值百万美元的问题。这就是我研究项目的起点。通常，如果你（你知道）在谷歌上搜索“恐音症”，你会发现恐音症是对咀嚼、呼吸、抽鼻子的厌恶，即通常来自口腔或鼻子的声音。所以一些研究人员很早就认为，这可能是一种与健康厌恶相关的反应。也许恐音症患者对抽鼻子有正常的厌恶感，因为这意味着（你知道）生病了。我不想生病。我不想靠近某个人
who is, you know, spittles coming out of their mouth as they're chewing. So maybe it's that kind of, maybe that's the disorder. Maybe that's the feeling. But I, so myself, I have misophonia. And I knew that I am bothered by more than just chewing sounds. I'm bothered by things like a clock ticking or water dripping or typing or a pen clicking or the list goes on. But my experience of it is more than just mouth or nose. And I was like, the idea of it being a health discussed thing doesn't quite track why I would hate the sound of typing or a mouse clicking for instance. So I came on the scene as a graduate student and I was like, I want to experimentally test. Am I abnormal? Or is this a universal experience that others do have triggers that are not just mouth or nose? So one of my first studies I
（你知道）咀嚼时嘴里喷出唾沫。所以也许这就是那种疾病。也许这就是那种感觉。但我（我自己）患有恐音症。我知道我被困扰的不仅仅是咀嚼声。我被时钟滴答声、水滴声、打字声、按笔声等声音困扰，名单还在继续。但我的体验不仅仅是口腔或鼻子。我想，如果它是一种健康厌恶的东西，就无法解释为什么我会讨厌打字或鼠标点击的声音。所以我作为一名研究生进入这个领域，我想通过实验来测试。我不正常吗？还是说这是一种普遍的体验，其他人也有非口腔或鼻子的触发因素？所以我做的第一项研究之一是
did is I tested a variety of different sounds. So I started. started with mouth or no sounds produced by a human. So I gave participants clips of sounds like the chewing, the breathing, et cetera. And I contrasted that in two ways. One, I contrasted that with sounds also produced by a human being, but not from the mouth or nose. So these are things like tapping your fingers or typing or kicking your feet, walking, those types of things. And I did that because I wanted to remove that sort of health, disgust sort of component. But I wanted to keep a person in the picture because one another theory with misophonia is maybe it's a man that person is so rude I need someone to blame for a sound and so I wanted to keep a person that you could
我测试了各种不同的声音。所以我从人类产生的口腔或鼻子声音开始。所以我给参与者播放了咀嚼、呼吸等声音片段。我通过两种方式进行了对比。第一，我将其与人类产生但非口腔或鼻子的声音进行了对比。这些声音包括敲手指、打字、踢脚、走路等。我这样做是因为我想消除那种健康厌恶的成分。但我希望画面中仍然有人，因为恐音症的另一个理论是，也许是“天哪，那个人太粗鲁了”，我需要有人为声音负责，所以我希望保留一个你可以（例如）责怪的人。但随后我将这两者与一个完全没有人类的类别进行了对比，即动物（很多人会报告说，它们太可爱了，如果它们那样吃东西，他们也无能为力）以及自然声音，比如风铃或水滴声，这些是自然发生的，你无法真正责怪某人。我想知道如果恐音症只是口腔或鼻子的、人类产生的疾病，如果它是这种厌恶健康的反应，那么我应该只在第一种条件（即包含口腔、鼻子类别的条件）下看到恐音症患者和非恐音症患者之间的差异。
blame for instance but then I contrasted those two with a category that didn't have any humans in it at all so this is either animals which a lot of people will report like they're so cute they can't help it if they're eating like that for instance and so animals were important to me but also the nature sounds so like a wind chime or water dripping or things that kind of are just naturally occurring that you can't really blame someone on. And I wanted to know if misophonia is just an oral or nasal sort of human produced condition, if it's this disgust health sort of response, then I should only see differences between someone with misoponia and someone who doesn't have misophonia for that first condition, the condition that has that, you know, mouth, nose kind of category.
但在我的结果中，我发现这三种情况在恐音症患者和对照组之间都显示出显著差异。这向我表明，恐音症不仅仅是对咀嚼、呼吸的厌恶。它确实是最常见的，但并非唯一。所以我最近的一些研究确实利用了这一点，并注意到人们在被什么困扰方面存在广泛的差异。当我试图做一个实验，列出“这是我的触发声音类别，我试图让它尽可能广泛”时，我意识到我的恐音症参与者并没有被所有这些声音同样地困扰。所以我开始采用一种数据驱动的方法，如果可以这样说的话，我说：
But in my results, I found that all three of those showed a significant difference between people with misophonia and controls. And so it signaled to me that misophonia is more than just a condition to chewing, an aversion to chewing your breathing. It is the most common by all means, but it's not exclusive. And so some of my more recent research has really taken advantage of that and noticed that people have wide array of differences in what they're bothered by. And so as I tried to make an experiment that puts like, here is my category of trigger sounds and I'm trying to make it as broad as possible, I'm realizing that my participants with Necifonia aren't equally bothered by all of those sounds. And so I've started to kind of employ more of a data-driven approach, if you will, where I say,
“好吧，各位，这是我所有的声音。你们告诉我你们最被什么困扰。”然后我会在我的实验中使用这些声音。所以我发现这是一种很难以这种方式研究的疾病，但声音的数量、类型等确实存在个体差异。你问题的另一部分很快就是，它们之间是否有任何共同点。至少在我自己的工作中，我没有发现任何关于声学量表的东西。所以频率之类的东西通常是不同的。它们往往来自某种重复的性质，或者像咀嚼、水滴声那样有重复的滴水声。但关于这种重复如果可预测且每次都一样，还是不可预测，哪种更烦人，目前尚无定论。所以关于是声音本身重要，还是对声音的解读重要，还有很多东西需要研究。有很多事情正在发生。哇。现在，你已经对恐音症进行了神经影像学研究。当某人听到触发声音且该人患有恐音症时，大脑中发生了什么？是的。首先我要说，我所做的大部分工作都是观察大脑中的一般连接，而不是观察发生了什么激活。所以我将与你分享一些来自其他实验室的结果，他们更具体地解决了这个问题。例如，如果有人躺在核磁共振扫描仪中，他们正在听
all right, y'all, here are all my sounds that I have. You tell me what you're most bothered by. And then I'll use those in my experiment, for instance. And so I'm finding it is a difficult disorder to try to study in that way, but there are definitely individual differences in how many sounds, the types of sounds, all of that type of thing. And so the other part of your question real quick was, like if there's any commonality between them. And at least in my own work, I have not found anything on like the acoustic scale. So things like frequency and whatnot are often different. They tend to come from sort of a repetitive nature or things like, you know, the chewing, the water dripping where there's a repetitive drip. But the jury's out on whether that
一个他们不喜欢的声音，一个触发声音，研究人员已经表明大脑中有一个区域。它被称为岛叶（insula）。这是一个位于颞叶皮层下方的区域，它执行许多高级认知功能。所以它会做一些事情，比如帮助你集中注意力并忽略无关的事物。它会帮助你调节情绪。它还处理一些厌恶感。它做了很多不同的事情。研究人员发现，这个特定区域，特别是它的前岛叶部分，在恐音症患者听到触发声音时非常活跃，比对照组听到这种触发声音时，或者比你听到一般厌恶噪音时更活跃。所以这个岛叶有些特别之处。所以我深入研究，我想：
repetition is more bothersome if it's predictable and the same between each instance or whether it's unpredictable. So there's still so much to go on as far as whether it's the sound that's important or the interpretation of the sound. There's a lot that's going on. Wow. Now, you've done neuroimaging research on misophonia. What's happening in the brain when somebody hears a triggering sound and that person has misophonia? Yeah. And I'll start this by saying first, a lot of the work I've done have looked at general connections in the brain rather than activation of what's happening. So I'm going to share with you some results that have come from a few other labs that have addressed that question more specifically. So for instance, if someone is lying in an MRI scanner and they're listening
我想知道大脑中从这个岛叶发出的连接发生了什么。我这样做部分是因为神经影像学很昂贵。不是每个人都有机会自己扫描参与者。所以我利用了一些开放获取的数据库，在那里我可以查看通过现有数据获得的神经影像。所以我做的一件事是，我给参与者（你知道）恐音症评估量表，然后我观察他们大脑中发生了什么，即使他们没有在听声音。我们称之为“静息状态”。当他们处于静息状态时，他们的大脑是如何连接的？事实证明
to a sound that they don't like, a triggering sound, researchers have shown that there's an area of the brain. It's called the insula. It's an area that's kind of beneath your temporal cortex, and it does a lot of higher level cognitive functions. So it'll do things like helping you pay attention and ignore things that are irrelevant. It'll help you regulate your emotions. It also processes some disgust. It does a lot of different things. And so researchers have found that this particular region, specifically the anterior insula portion of it, is really active in people with misophonia when they hear a triggering sound, more so than when controls hear this triggering sound or more so when you're hearing just generally aversive noises. So there's something particular about this insula. So I swooped into and I was like,
患有恐音症、恐音症程度较高的人，往往从岛叶到一些关键区域有更多的连接。例如，像高级听觉皮层，即处理这些声音是什么的大脑部分，这些噪音的复杂性质，与这个岛叶连接得更多，这个岛叶告诉你这是一个情绪化的事情，我需要注意它或者不需要。我还发现一般的岛叶与运动皮层中的事物相连，这是另一个小组同样发现的，这有点令人困惑，想知道人们是否在模仿他们不喜欢的声音作为一种潜在的应对机制，或者运动皮层中是否有更多东西可能导致人们对这些特定声音产生反应。因为并非所有声音都涉及人类运动，所以我自己也感到困惑。还有更多我正在探索的事情。恐音症与其他心理健康状况之间有联系吗？我想到的是，例如，焦虑症、强迫症，甚至
I wonder what's going on in the brain with connectivity from this insula. And so I do this partially because neuroimaging is expensive. Not everyone has access to being able to scan participants on their own. So I've kind of taken advantage of some open access databases and things where I can look at neuroimaging through data that already exist. So one of the things I'll do is I gave participants, you know, assessment scales of misophonia and then I looked at what's going on in their brain even when they're not listening to sounds. what we call that at rest. When they're just at rest, how is their brain connected? And it turns out
自闭症谱系障碍，例如。简短的回答是，它们之间有很多共存。所以很多患有恐音症的人也会表达类似焦虑的事情。他们会说：“是的，我也经历过，或者我也被诊断出患有焦虑症。”最初，许多研究恐音症的研究人员是强迫症领域的研究人员。所以有些人认为也许恐音症属于强迫症的范畴。也许这就是它最适合的地方。但我认为简短的回答是，随着不同的团队试图探究这个问题，即是否存在共病？
that folks with misophonia, higher misovonia, tend to have more connections from that insula to some key regions. So things, for instance, like higher level auditory cortex, the part of the brain that is processing what these sounds are, the complex nature of these noises, is more connected to this insula that is telling you that this is an emotional thing and I need to either pay attention to it or not. I've also found just general insulas connected to things in the motor cortex, which is another group is similarly found, and it's kind of a baffling, wondering if people are mimicking the sound they're not liking as a potential coping mechanism, or whether there's more in the motor cortex that might be leading to why people are having reactions to these particular sounds. Because they're not all sounds that involve human movement, so I'm kind of baffled myself. There are more things that I'm exploring with them. Is there a connection between misophonia and other mental health conditions? I'm thinking, for example, anxiety disorders, obsessive compulsive disorder, or even
恐音症患者和其他这些疾病之间是否有任何共存？他们发现，虽然确实存在一些重叠，有些人确实有，但并没有一个普遍的疾病能最好地与之相关。所以恐音症不是某一种特定事物的特征。因此，领域内有人争论说恐音症应该是一种独立的疾病，不适合归入任何其他疾病。而且非常迷人的是，你最后提到了自闭症，这是最近受到一些研究关注的事情，因为自闭症患者经历的那种感官困难有很多相似之处，也许像声音可能对他们来说很烦人，或者他们可能没有那么注意到它们，
somewhere autism spectrum disorder, for example. So the short answer is there's a lot of co-occurrence between those. So a lot of folks who have misophonia will similarly express things like anxiety. They'll be like, yes, I also experience or I've also been diagnosed with anxiety, for instance. originally a lot of the researchers who studied misophonia were researchers in the OCD field. And so some folks were like maybe misophonia is under the umbrella of OCD. Maybe that's kind of where it best fits. But I think the short answer, as different groups have sort of probed that question being like, is there comorbidity?
有很多感官困难可能与恐音症重叠。一些研究人员正在专门研究这一点，以确定它是否是一种类似的机制，是否是正在发生的不同的事情。所以我认为未来会有很多非常酷的研究来理清这一点。但到目前为止，我们不能自信地说它与这些事物中的某一个最相似。你还研究了这些声音如何影响人们的认知和社会判断。那么你在研究中发现了什么？是的，很多有趣的事情。
Is there any co-occurrence between folks who have misophonia and any of these other conditions? And what they have found is that while there is some overlap and some people, there is not one universal condition that it best relates to. So misophonia is not characteristic of one particular thing. And so it's kind of been argued in the field that misophonia should be its own distinct disorder doesn't best fit under any of these other ones. And it's really fascinating, too, you mentioned autism at the end, and that's something that's recently been getting some research, because there are a lot of similarities with folks with autism experienced in that sort of sensory difficulty, maybe things like sounds might be bothersome to them or they might not notice them as much,
我研究认知和社会判断，部分是因为我从人们那里得到了很多自我报告，他们说：“轶事上，天哪，那个人太粗鲁了，那个人咀嚼的方式像个穴居人”，仅仅是轶事上就给我关于一个人的判断。所以我心想，我想知道这是否是一件普遍的事情。所以我对此进行了测试。所以我设计了一个实验，让参与者研究与环境中声音配对的人脸。所以我说：“好吧，假装这个人正在发出声音。”我给了他们各种声音，触发因素、非触发因素等，并要求他们做各种事情。我在后续行动中要求他们告诉我，如果他们在记忆任务中见过那张脸
there's a lot of kind of sensory difficulty that might overlap misophonia. And some researchers are looking into that specifically to note if it's a similar mechanism, if it's a different thing that's going on. And so I think there's a lot of future research that will be really cool to tease that apart. But as of now, we can't confidently say that it's most similar to one of these things. You've also looked at how these sounds affect people's cognitive and social judgment. So what have you found in your research? Yes, a lot of interesting things.
他们没有意识到。所以我无意中得到了他们的记忆、反应时间表现的测量结果。我在研究中有各种不同的指标。但我发现有趣的关键点是，当人们能够正确记住与他们看到的脸配对的声音时。例如，如果我给你看一张人的脸，它与咀嚼声配对，而你不喜欢咀嚼，咀嚼是你的触发声音之一，并且你记得当你第一次看到它时那张脸与咀嚼配对，你确实会显著地将那个人评价为更
So I've studied cognitive and social judgments partially because I get a lot of self-report from folks that are like anecdotally, man, that person's so rude, that person is a caveman in the way they chew, like giving me judgments about a person just anecdotally. And so I was like, I wonder if this is a universal thing. And so I put this to the test. And so I designed an experiment where I had participants study faces of people paired with sounds in the environment. So I said, all right, pretend this person is making the sound, for instance. And I gave them a variety of sounds, triggers, non-triggers, et cetera, and asked them to do a variety of things. I asked them and follow up to tell me if they had seen that face before in a memory task
不可爱，当你稍后再次看到他们时，前提是你患有恐音症。所以这并不是一种普遍的体验，我觉得这非常迷人，只有恐音症患者才会对人们应用这种社会判断。所以它正在渗透我们与人的经历，我认为这也是另一个值得进一步探索的有趣方面。我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论一种相关的疾病，称为“恐动症”（misochinesia），即对他人动作的反应，以及恐音症对人们工作、人际关系和日常生活的影响。你的夏天现在开始，家得宝（The Home Depot）有阵亡将士纪念日的优惠。是时候启动
that they weren't aware of. So I'm inadvertently getting measures of their memory, their reaction time performance. I have a variety of different metrics in the study. But the key thing that I find interesting in it is that when folks are able to correctly remember what sound was paired with a face they saw. So if I showed you, for instance, a person's face and it was paired with the sound of chewing, and you don't like chewing, chewing is one of your trigger sounds, and you remembered that that face was paired with chewing when you first saw it, you do significantly rate that person as less
夏季烧烤了，Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤炉特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？
likable when you're shown them again later, only if you have misophonia, though. So that is not a universal experience, which I find very fascinating, that only folks with misophonia apply that social judgment to folks. And so it is kind of permeating our experiences with people, which I think is also another interesting facet to explore further. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about a related condition called misochinesia, a reaction to other people's movements and about the effects that misophonia can have on people's work, relationships, and daily lives. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up
足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。
summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。现在，当我研究这个播客时，我读到了一种叫做“恐动症”的疾病，这是对他人动作而不是声音的反应。这也是一个活跃的研究领域吗？它和恐音症一样普遍吗？这也是一个最近活跃的领域，肯定的。所以那里有几种想法。因为，同样，关于它的工作太少了，我不认为我们能肯定地知道。
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
所以一些小组认为恐动症有点属于恐音症的范畴。这是对某些重复的视觉或声音的厌恶，任何大多数人不会回应的环境事物。所以也许这就是恐动症。也许这就像某人摇晃或摆动腿，例如。这不一定与声音相关。但也许那种重复的视觉效果同样会触及那种重复性质的声音所带来的负面情绪反应。
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Now, as I was researching this podcast, I read about a condition called misochinesia, which is a reaction to other people's movements rather than sounds. Is this an active area of research as well? And is it as common as misophonia? Also a recently active area, for sure. So there's kind of a couple camps of ideas there. Because, again, there's so little work on it that I don't think we confidently know for sure.
所以有些人认为它可能共享类似的机制，尽管它是不同的感官输入，视觉与声音。很多人也承认恐音症确实包括一些视觉输入。正如最近定义的，2020 年有一个恐音症的共识定义，它明确承认恐音症是对与这些声音相关的声音或视觉的厌恶。所以这有点奇怪，但例如，我一直用咀嚼作为我的例子，只是因为它最简单。但如果你不喜欢某人咀嚼的声音，即使那个声音被去掉了。例如，如果你透过餐厅窗户看，你听不到咀嚼声，但你仍然可以看到那个人的下巴移动？比如，
So some groups think that misochinesia is kind of under the umbrella of misophonia. It's this aversion to certain repetitive sights or sounds, any sort of environmental thing that most people don't respond to. So maybe that's for misochinesia. Maybe that's something like someone shaking or swinging their leg, for instance. And that doesn't have a sound associated with it necessarily. But maybe that repetitive kind of sight similarly hits the same negative emotional response that sound that is repetitive in that nature.
你可以看到与咀嚼相关的重复动作。这同样会触发那种相同的反应。所以这是一种恐音症确实包含一些视觉成分的想法。所以恐动症可能正在利用类似的东西。它可能有点不同，因为没有声音包含在内，所以听觉皮层之类的东西并不太适用。所以我只在过去几年里看到了一些研究恐动症或任何重叠的最新文章。似乎有患有恐动症的人也经历恐音症，反之亦然。但同样，在我们的大多数研究中，不是一一对应的。所以看起来并不是每个患有 A 病的人都有 B 病。
So some folks think it might share a similar mechanism, even though it's a different sensory input, vision versus sound. A lot of folks, too, acknowledge that misophonia does include some visual input. So as defined recently, there's a 2020 consensus definition of misophonia, and it specifically acknowledges misophonia as an aversion to sounds or sites associated with those sounds. And so it's a little bit bizarre, but something, for instance, I keep using chewing as my example, just because it's easiest. But if you don't like the sound of someone chew, even if that sound is taken away. So for instance, what if you're looking through a restaurant window where you can't hear chewing, but you can still see that person's jaw move? Like,
让我们换个话题，谈谈恐音症对人们生活的影响。你从人们那里听到关于恐音症如何影响他们的人际关系、工作、日常功能的消息吗？既然你也患有这种病，它对你有什么影响？是的。以各种方式。每个人经历它的程度不同，极端程度也不同。第一，如果你好奇，如果有人需要证明恐音症是真实的，我鼓励他们上网，比如 Reddit，只需阅读恐音症患者的帖子，他们说：“帮帮我。我需要离开这个环境。我该如何处理我的老板？我的伴侣在制造所有这些噪音。”这只是各种发泄机制，以了解这
you can see that repetitive movement associated with chewing. That will similarly trigger that same sort of reaction. And so it's an idea that misophonia does kind of involve some visual component as well. And so misoconnesia might be tapping into similar things. It might be a little bit different because there's no sound included, so things like auditory cortex doesn't really apply as much. And so I've only seen some recent articles in the last few years studying misochinesia or any overlap. It seems that there are folks with misocinnesia that also experience misophonia and vice versa. But again, in most of our research, not a one-to-one correspondence. So it doesn't seem to be like everyone who has condition A has condition B.
实际上干扰了多少。但我认为它确实倾向于轶事上，我听到人们谈论，“天哪，是的，我不得不离开我的伴侣。我的伴侣发出的咀嚼声我无法忍受。我和他们谈过。这根本不是他们能改变的事情。所以，我做不到。对我来说做不到。”
Let's change gears for a minute and talk about the impact that misophonia can have on people's lives. What do you hear from people about how misophonia affects their relationships, their work, their daily functioning? And since you also have it, how has it affected you? Yeah. So in a variety of ways. And everyone experiences it kind of different to different extremes. One, if you're ever curious, if anyone needs to justify that misophonia is real, I encourage them to go online to like a Reddit and just read the posts of people with misophonia being like, help me. I need to leave this environment. How do I deal with my boss? my partner is making all these noises. There's just like various venting kind of mechanisms to get a sense of how much this
也许这是一个，我在办公室工作。我坐在一个开放空间的隔间里，每个人都在我周围打字。我戴着（你知道）耳机，但它们不能完全阻挡它。我真的不能在这份工作中。如果我坐在这种环境中，我就不能有效地完成我的工作。所以，讽刺的是，居家办公的那个时代对很多恐音症患者来说是好的，因为它把他们带出了那个空间。所以人们在寻找更兼容的不同工作。
actually interferes. But I think it does tend to anecdotally, I hear people talk about, man, yeah, I had to leave my partner. My partner made chewing noises that I couldn't deal with. And I talked to them about it. And it just, it was not a thing they could change. And so that's, I can't do that. Can't do that for me.
它肯定也会影响学术功能。这是我成长过程中经历的事情，也是许多倡导者正在努力的方向。就像为恐音症学生提供住宿一样，因为如果你曾经（你知道）在安静的考场里，当你们所有高年级学生都在参加那个（你知道）SAT 考试或任何考试时。人们用铅笔在纸上乱涂乱画，或者也许他们在按圆珠笔，或者无论它看起来是什么样。它太让人分心了，以至于恐音症患者会真的脱离，无法专注于他们正在做的事情。所以这是其中之一，现在，
Maybe that's a, I work in an office job. And I sit in an open space cubicle where everyone's typing around me. and I'm wearing, you know, headphones, but they don't block it out completely. I literally can't be in this job. I can't do my job effectively if I'm sitting in this environment. And so, ironically, the work from home, that era was good for a lot of folks with misophonia because it took them out of that space. So it's folks looking for different jobs that are more compatible.
至少（你知道）作为一名大学教授，我看到学生有住宿条件，上面写着：“好吧，这个学生将在一个单独的、安静的隔音室里参加考试。这个人参加考试时不会有任何听觉干扰。”所以至少在这一点上，它得到了一点更多的认可。但至少它是干扰生活许多方面的事情，无论是人际关系、工作、学校等。除了分开学生（例如）让他们参加考试，这样他们就不必听到触发声音，还有哪些其他选择或治疗方法可供恐音症患者使用，研究表明什么真正有效？
It definitely affects academic functioning as well. That's something that I experienced growing up, and that's something that a lot of advocates are working towards. It's like accommodations for students with misophonia, because if you've ever been, been, you know, in a silent testing room as you're all seniors taking that, you know, SAT test or whatever. And people are scribbling with their pencil on the paper or maybe they're clicking their ballpoint pen or whatever it looks like. It is so distracting that folks with misophonia will literally disengage and not be able to focus on what they're doing. And so it's one of those where now,
是的。所以很多研究人员在某种案例研究或较小的样本量中研究了这一点，以确定：“好吧，是否有似乎有效的治疗方法？”所以不同的临床心理学家做了诸如认知行为疗法（CBT）之类的事情，帮助人们重新构建他们对声音的认知解读。所以我提到了几次，（你知道）人们认为这个人咀嚼的方式非常粗鲁。但也许如果你试着说服你的大脑，“天哪，这个人只是，他们刚做了下巴手术，他们必须那样咀嚼。那不是他们的错。他们只是需要，那是他们现在必须摄入食物的方式。”如果你帮助重新表述你对
at least, you know, as a college professor, I'm seeing folks with accommodations that say, all right, this student is going to take their test in a separate, quiet sound booth. This person is going to not have any auditory distraction when they take their test. And so it's at least getting a little more recognition as far as that is concerned. But it's at least something that is interfering with many aspects of life, whether it be that relationship, the work, the school, etc. Other than separating students, let's say, as they're taking tests so that they don't have to hear the triggering sounds, what are some other options or treatments that are available for people who have misophonia, and what does the research show about what really works?
声音的思考方式，你可能会减少对它的情绪反应。所以如果你去看一位能用 CBT 练习帮助你的精神科医生，似乎会有一些帮助。不过，我最喜欢的应对技巧之一，作为一名研究这些声音的感觉或感知的人，我对此感到非常兴奋。加州大学圣克鲁斯分校的一项研究表明，场景的视觉表现可以改变你听到潜在声音的方式。所以有一个常见的现象叫做“麦格克效应”（McGurk effect），即如果你有视觉和听觉输入，你的视觉输入在你的解读中往往会占上风。为了给你一个具体的例子。研究人员已经表明，如果你（例如）看到某人通过吸管喝东西的视频，他们的杯子，而你正在听到那种吸食声，你（患有恐音症）会发现这非常令人厌恶。你看到了你不喜欢的触发因素的视觉效果，并且你听到了你不喜欢的触发因素。然而，如果你配对完全相同的声音，那种吸食声，但不是某人通过吸管吸食，如果你给他们看（例如）像一条潺潺的小溪，像一种令人愉悦的平静声音，但把它排成一行，看起来它可能潜在地产生你听到的声音，你实际上对它的反应会降低。所以这是一个有趣的现象，证明了不仅仅是纯粹的声学让你感到困扰，否则你会对相同的声学做出相同的反应。
Yeah. So a lot of researchers looked into this in sort of kind of case studies or smaller sample sizes to be like, all right, is there a treatment that it seems to be effective? And so different clinical psychologists have done things like cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT that helps people to kind of reframe their cognitive interpretation of the sound. So I've mentioned a few times, you know, people think this person is super rude in the way that they're chewing. But maybe if you try to convince your brain, man, this person is just, they just got jaw surgery and they have to chew that way. Like, that's not their fault. Like, they just need to, that's the way that they have to consume food right now. Like, if you help to rephrase the way that you are thinking about the
是的。因此，许多研究人员通过案例研究或较小的样本量对此进行了调查，试图找出是否有某种治疗方法似乎是有效的。不同的临床心理学家尝试过认知行为疗法（CBT）等方法，帮助人们重新构建对声音的认知解读。正如我之前提到的，人们可能会觉得某人咀嚼的方式非常粗鲁。但如果你试着说服自己的大脑，比如，这个人刚做了下颌手术，不得不那样咀嚼，那不是他们的错，他们只是需要以那种方式进食。如果你能帮助自己重新调整对这种声音的看法，
sound, you might reduce your emotional response to it. So there is some help that seems to occur if you go to a psychiatrist who can help you with CBT kind of practices. One of my favorite, though, coping skills that I am really excited about as someone who researches kind of the sensation or perception of these sounds. There is a study down at UC Santa Cruz showing that a visual representation of like a scene can alter how you hear the underlying sound. So there's a common phenomenon called the McGurk effect, which is the idea that if you have visual and auditory input, your visual input kind of tends to win over a little bit in what you're interpreting. So to give you a concrete example. The researchers have shown that if you're, for instance, seeing a video of someone slurping
你或许就能减轻对它的情绪反应。因此，如果你去看精神科医生，他们可以帮助你进行CBT练习，这似乎确实会有所帮助。不过，作为一名研究这些声音感觉或感知的人，我最喜欢的一种应对技巧让我感到非常兴奋。加州大学圣克鲁兹分校的一项研究表明，场景的视觉呈现可以改变你对底层声音的听觉感知。有一个常见的现象叫“麦格克效应”（McGurk effect），即如果你同时有视觉和听觉输入，你的视觉输入往往会在你的解读中占据主导地位。举个具体的例子，研究人员已经证明，如果你看到某人通过吸管喝东西的视频，
through a straw, their cup, and you're hearing that slurping sound, you're going to, with misophonia, you're going to find that really aversive. You're seeing a visual of a trigger you don't like, and you're hearing a trigger you don't like. However, if you pair that same exact sound, that slurping sound, but instead of a person slurping through a straw, if you show them, for instance, like a babbling brook, like a nice calming kind of sound, but line it up so it looks like it could potentially be producing the sound you're hearing, you actually have a reduced response to it. So it's an interesting phenomenon to demonstrate that it's not just pure acoustics, that's bothersome to you, because otherwise you would respond the same to the same acoustic
并且听到了那种吸吮的声音，对于患有恐音症的人来说，你会觉得这非常令人反感。你看到了你不喜欢的触发源的视觉画面，也听到了你不喜欢的触发声音。然而，如果你将完全相同的声音——那种吸吮声——与不同的画面配对，比如不再是某人通过吸管喝东西，而是展示一条潺潺的小溪，一种令人平静的声音，但将其与你听到的声音对齐，使其看起来像是发出了那种声音，你实际上会对它产生较小的反应。这是一个有趣的现象，证明了困扰你的不仅仅是纯粹的声学特征，否则你对相同的声学信号会有相同的反应。
information. It's demonstrating that how you feel what you think the sound is, how you identify it, or you think it's coming from your associations with that sound that are actually controlling how much you react to it. So it's a fun kind of insight that could lead to some therapeutic approaches if maybe you convince yourselves either with a visual image or in your mind that that sound is coming from a different source than it actually is could produce your response. I want to ask about something that's different but possibly related. It's called ASMR or autonomous sensory meridian response. There's a lot about this on the internet. And I've heard it described almost as the opposite of misophony. It's a pleasant sensory response to certain sounds
信息。它证明了你的感受、你对声音的认知、你如何识别它，或者你认为它来自哪里，这些联想实际上控制了你对它的反应程度。所以这是一个有趣的见解，如果能通过视觉图像或在脑海中说服自己，那个声音来自与实际不同的源头，或许就能产生治疗方法，从而改变你的反应。我想问一个不同但可能相关的问题。它被称为ASMR，即自发性知觉经络反应。互联网上有很多关于这个的内容。我听说它几乎被描述为恐音症的对立面。它是对某些声音的一种愉悦的感官反应，
or visual stimuli, like a brain tingle. Do you think these two situations are related and could studying one tell us something important about the other? Also a hot button question. And one that I think very genuinely could be a related thing. I've similarly heard that, you know, they're opposite ends of the same spectrum. And as you might notice with different sounds that, lead to ASMR, a lot of them overlap the sounds that are bothersome to someone with misophonia. So one of my classic ways I love to introduce presentations when I gave a talk on misophonia is I show an ASMR video from YouTube. So you'll find tons of them of folks, for instance, eating into their microphone and making all of those chewing noises. And I will play that video,
或视觉刺激，就像大脑发麻一样。你认为这两种情况有关联吗？研究其中一个是否能告诉我们关于另一个的重要信息？这也是一个热门话题。我认为这确实可能是一个相关的事情。我同样听说，它们是同一光谱的两端。正如你可能注意到的，导致ASMR的不同声音中，有很多与恐音症患者感到困扰的声音重叠。所以，当我做关于恐音症的演讲时，我喜欢介绍的方式之一就是播放一段来自YouTube的ASMR视频。你会发现很多这样的视频，比如人们对着麦克风吃东西，发出所有的咀嚼声。我会播放那个视频，
mind you, with my ears plugged because it's aversive to me. But I'll pull my audience and I'll be like, how many of you guys enjoyed that or found that, you know, tingling? And without fail, no matter what group I'm in, a good fifth of them at least will raise their hand and be like, yeah, that was great. You could keep playing that. And it's a really cool demonstration to be like, this exact sound that I had to plug my ears to is one that you enjoy. And so it's fascinating to me to know why that same sound might lead to completely opposite reactions in different people. And it's one that, again, all of these conditions we've talked about today, whether it was misophonia, ASMR, mesokinesia, are so new in what their names are that they haven't gotten a ton of quality research behind them
请注意，我塞住了耳朵，因为这对我来说是厌恶的。但我会询问观众，我会问，你们中有多少人喜欢这个，或者觉得它让你感到发麻？毫无疑问，无论我在哪个群体中，至少有五分之一的人会举手说，是的，这太棒了。你可以继续播放。这是一个非常酷的演示，说明了同一个我必须塞住耳朵才能忍受的声音，却是你所享受的。所以，了解为什么同一个声音在不同人身上会导致完全相反的反应，这对我来说非常迷人。而且，我们今天谈论的所有这些情况，无论是恐音症、ASMR还是运动恐惧症，它们的名字都太新了，以至于还没有得到大量高质量的研究支持，
to be able to fully disentangle, you know, how much should they overlap? Why do they share these common patterns, for instance? So I think you'll see more work on that moving forward. There's been some survey responses, folks with misophonia report also having ASMR to different sounds, which is interesting that they would experience the same reaction, but obviously not to the same stimulus. But again, not a one-to-one kind of correspondence. So stay tuned for more research on that. I'm curious to know if that is something that turns out to be an effective comparison group. Well, given that this is all fairly recent in terms of scientific research,
无法完全理清它们应该有多少重叠？例如，为什么它们有这些共同的模式？所以我认为未来你会看到更多关于这方面的研究。已经有一些调查反馈显示，恐音症患者也报告说对不同的声音有ASMR反应，这很有趣，他们会有同样的反应，但显然不是针对同一个刺激。但同样，这并不是一一对应的关系。所以请继续关注这方面的更多研究。我很好奇这是否会成为一个有效的对照组。嗯，考虑到所有这些在科学研究方面都相当新，
do we know when misophonia typically develops in people? Are they born with it? Does it emerge at a certain age? Is there any genetic link? Yeah. This is something I'd love to dig more into. So most of what we know here is a little bit anecdotal. So when surveys have asked people with misophonia, when do you kind of remember the onset occurring? Most people, this seems to be a
我们知道恐音症通常在什么时候发展吗？他们是天生就有吗？它是在某个年龄段出现的吗？有遗传联系吗？是的。这是我很想深入研究的问题。我们所知道的大部分内容都有点轶事性质。所以当调查问恐音症患者，你记得什么时候开始出现这种情况时，大多数人，这似乎是一个
pretty common response that early adolescence is when people first start to experience this. So you'll often see in like the 10 to 12 year old range of when people will express their onset of misophonia. And there's some fascinating, maybe social reasons for this. You're starting to go through puberty, you're starting to maybe go through the I hate my parents stage or like I am annoyed of being here. And one thing that I find particularly interesting about Misaponia is it does seem to affect the people who are closest to you the most. People making sounds that are like your family members are going to bother you more than strangers making that same sound. And so it is one thing where, for instance, if you're a 12 year old and you're stuck in your parents' house, you can't move
相当普遍的回答，即青春期早期是人们第一次开始经历这种情况的时候。所以你经常会看到在10到12岁这个范围内，人们会表达恐音症的开始。这背后有一些迷人的、可能是社会性的原因。你开始经历青春期，你可能开始经历“我讨厌我的父母”阶段，或者“我对待在这里感到厌烦”。关于恐音症，我发现特别有趣的一点是，它似乎对你最亲近的人影响最大。家人发出的声音比陌生人发出的同样声音更让你困扰。所以，例如，如果你是一个12岁的孩子，被困在父母家里，你无法搬
out. You're in an environment where you can't control it. And now that sound, for you, from your parents or your siblings is going to really irritate you more than for instance someone who's an adult who can be like, I have the ability to leave this apartment I am in, for instance. Or if you're able to remove yourself from the situation and have more control, it sounds a little bit easier. So there's like maybe some speculation to why onset in early adolescence might be interesting. But as far as I'm aware, there haven't been really any longitudinal studies or studies across time where they've been able to say, all right, I am looking at a brain scan or survey from a child, you know, pre 10 to 12 to know whether or not in which children it tends to develop.
出去。你处于一个无法控制的环境中。现在，来自父母或兄弟姐妹的声音对你来说，真的比一个成年人更让你恼火，因为成年人可以像说“我有能力离开我所在的这个公寓”那样。或者，如果你能够脱离这种情况并拥有更多的控制权，听起来会容易一些。所以，关于为什么青春期早期发病可能很有趣，也许有一些推测。但据我所知，还没有真正进行过任何纵向研究或跨时间的研究，能够说，好吧，我正在观察一个孩子（10到12岁之前）的脑部扫描或调查，以了解它是否会在哪些孩子身上发展。
I would love to do a study where I look at younger kids and I get surveys of anxiety or depression or autism or whatever it looks like. Maybe we do brain scans, for instance. And then I invite them back every couple years to be like, all right, can I predict which of you will end up experiencing this misophonia condition using some of your earlier symptoms. If we can predict it ahead of time, then likely we can be able to reduce the effects of it. And so that's something that I think future research will definitely dig into when there's more funding to be able to do those types of long studies. The other thing that you asked about was genetics. And I think that's an interesting concept too, because a lot of folks with misophonia will report like, oh yeah, my dad also
我很想做一个研究，观察更小的孩子，获取关于焦虑、抑郁、自闭症或任何类似情况的调查。也许我们做脑部扫描。然后每隔几年邀请他们回来，看看我是否能利用你们早期的一些症状来预测你们中谁最终会患上这种恐音症。如果我们能提前预测它，那么很可能我们就能减少它的影响。所以，当有更多资金能够进行这些类型的长期研究时，我认为未来的研究肯定会深入探讨这一点。你问的另一件事是遗传学。我认为这也是一个有趣的概念，因为很多恐音症患者会报告说，哦，是的，我爸爸也
has it. Or like my aunt expresses this too. And so again, you can take that a couple different ways. There is a nature component. There's something in your genes that is leading to this feeling. Or it could be that you were raised in a house where people were really sensitive to noises. And so you started to attune yourself and also be sensitive to noises. So it could be a nurture, an environmental factor as well. As with all things in psychology. More research is needed to fully tease those apart.
有这种情况。或者我的阿姨也有这种表现。所以，你可以从几个不同的角度来看待这个问题。有一个先天因素。你的基因里有什么东西导致了这种感觉。或者可能是因为你在一个对噪音非常敏感的家庭中长大。所以你开始调整自己，也对噪音变得敏感。所以这可能也是一种后天环境因素。正如心理学中的所有事物一样，需要更多的研究来完全理清这些因素。
But I think that they're interesting avenues to go down, that there very well could be a genetic component. There could be an environmental component. Man, and that twin study would be awesome to be able to test. and to give these apart. If I hypothetically could find twins raised in different areas where one of them had misophonia, one of them didn't. That is ideal research study. For our listeners who might be living or working with people who have misophonia, what can they do to be supportive and help the people around them? Yeah, I love this. My biggest advice is just to communicate. So like, for instance, I have a very loving partner who is able, I'm able to say like, hey, I'm feeling this
但我认为它们是值得探索的有趣途径，很可能存在遗传成分。也可能存在环境成分。天哪，那个双胞胎研究将是测试和区分这些因素的绝佳机会。如果我假设能找到在不同地区长大的双胞胎，其中一个患有恐音症，另一个没有。那是理想的研究。对于那些可能与恐音症患者一起生活或工作的听众，他们能做些什么来提供支持并帮助周围的人呢？是的，我喜欢这个。我最大的建议就是沟通。所以，例如，我有一个非常有爱心的伴侣，我能够说，嘿，我现在有这种
motion right now or I'm having trouble with this sound. And it's like, great, we're going to turn on some music. We're going to, I'm going to stop eating this food. I'm going to move to a different location. Like a very open communication is one of the best things you can do in a non-judgmental way. Because if someone with misophonia feels like they can't speak up or that they have to kind of suffer in silence, it's going to be a lot worse for them. And so I think if you are around someone with misophonia, I think both asking them like what kind of things bother you just so I know that I'm not doing him. If someone's bothered by eating chips, don't pull out a bag of chips in front of them, just like some obvious stuff like that. But I think in general, asking, talking to them,
情绪，或者我对这个声音有困难。然后就像，太好了，我们要打开一些音乐。我们要，我会停止吃这种食物。我会搬到不同的地方。像这样非常开放的沟通，以一种非评判的方式，是你所能做的最好的事情之一。因为如果一个恐音症患者觉得他们不能说出来，或者他们必须默默忍受，这对他们来说会更糟。所以我认为如果你在恐音症患者身边，我认为既要问他们什么样的事情会困扰你，这样我就知道我不会做这些事。如果有人被吃薯片的声音困扰，就不要在他们面前拿出一袋薯片，就像一些显而易见的事情一样。但我认为总的来说，询问、与他们交谈，
validating that it's a thing that they're actually experiencing and not just them being moody and not wanting to be around people or something. Like chalking it up to validating that it's a thing, a real thing, I think is super helpful. You talked a little bit about things that you would like to study, but just to wrap up, do you have any ongoing studies right now? What are you looking at. Yeah. So right now, since I'm super new, we're going a little basic. So one of the things I'm currently looking at is expanding the types of sounds that are bothersome to people with misophonia in a sound bank. So one of the things with research is it's helpful to present sounds, but as I've said, everyone's bothered by different sounds. So one of the things I've got a group of
确认这确实是他们正在经历的事情，而不是他们只是情绪化、不想和人在一起之类的。把这归结为确认这是一件真实的事情，我认为非常有帮助。你谈到了一些你想研究的事情，但为了总结，你现在有正在进行的研究吗？你在关注什么？是的。所以现在，因为我是新手，我们做得比较基础。所以我目前正在研究的一件事是，在声音库中扩展恐音症患者感到困扰的声音类型。所以研究的一件事是，提供声音是有帮助的，但正如我所说，每个人被困扰的声音都不同。所以我有一组
students doing is aggregating a variety of sounds from different sources, multiple examples of all those sounds. So I could get a better idea and better use it in experiments to get a sense of why certain sounds are bothersome, why people like certain sounds and not others. So right now, I'm just expanding sound banks that can be used in future research. But more things on the horizon. Well, Dr. Hanson, this has been really interesting. I want to thank you for joining me. Yeah, thank you so much for having you. It's been fun. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, YouTube, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard,
学生正在做的事情是从不同来源收集各种声音，所有这些声音的多个例子。这样我就能更好地了解并更好地在实验中使用它，以了解为什么某些声音令人困扰，为什么人们喜欢某些声音而不喜欢其他声音。所以现在，我只是在扩展可以用于未来研究的声音库。但地平线上还有更多的事情。好吧，汉森博士，这真的很有趣。我想感谢你加入我。是的，非常感谢你的邀请。这很有趣。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、YouTube、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，
please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Did you know if your windows are bare, indoor temperatures can go up 20 degrees? Get ahead of summer with custom window treatments like solar roller shades from blinds.com and save up to 45% off during the Memorial Day Early Access sale.
请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的节目有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Winerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。你知道吗，如果你的窗户是裸露的，室内温度可能会升高20度？通过blinds.com的太阳能卷帘等定制窗饰，提前为夏天做好准备，并在阵亡将士纪念日提前访问促销期间节省高达45%的费用。
Whether you want to DIY it, or have a pro handle everything, we've got you. Free samples, real design experts, and zero pressure. Just help when you need it. Shop up to 45% off site-wide right now during the Early Access Memorial Day sale at blinds.com. Rules and restrictions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论你是想自己动手，还是让专业人士处理一切，我们都能满足你。免费样品，真正的设计专家，零压力。当你需要时，只需寻求帮助。现在就在blinds.com的阵亡将士纪念日提前访问促销期间，全场最高可享45%的折扣。规则和限制适用。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。